one year ago today lives were changed
forever 23 year old Tina tinter and her
dog were killed in a fiery car crash now
the person police say caused the crash
former Raiders player Henry rugs it
happened near the corner of rainbow and
Spring Valley Parkway just north of
Tropicana and actually it was a short
distance from their respective homes now
it's now one year later and still no
trial date has been set and tonight the
community continues to remember the
young woman
and what we were trying to do is help
out you know it's our community and a
mural with Tina tinter and her dog Max
outside the property of Genesis asibo a
daily reminder she says of a horrific
night when tragedy happened behind her
family's home it was just a really
horrible night and that's why we went
out to see if we can help her out or
anything we didn't even know what was
going on and then when we saw the
scenario the car and everything be on
fire it was very scary
according to Metro Police 23 year old
tintor and her dog were killed on
November 2nd of last year when former
Las Vegas Raider Henry rugs was driving
156 miles per hour seconds before
hitting her car reports show rugs blood
alcohol level was twice the legal limit
we reached out to the tinchar family but
we were told they did not want to
comment instead the knock be injury law
releasing this statement on behalf of
the tinter family which reads in part we
pray that no one ever forgets Tina and
Max and that no one else has to endure
the Indescribable pain that comes from a
loved one being killed because someone
chooses to get behind the wheel while
intoxicated a life was taken too young
and um
um it's just hopefully we keep it alive
you know hopefully you know um just to
remember her today the mural which was
organized by the victim's uncle is
filled with flowers and Candy acibo says
it's a popular Gathering where family
and friends come to remember teen and
her dog while Justice continues to push
forward in court it could have happened
to myself my
my
community and if
I'm sure that
be there for each other
well rugs is still on high-level
electronic monitoring he is scheduled
back in court on February 1st for a
preliminary hearing and that is when a
judge will decide if there is enough
evidence to send the case to trial